let's go Mraz my spine fat welcome back
to some a caves pity whoa when on yup
what probably back up to the classroom
right oh [ __ ] there's yes hello my nan
yup what you're missing minute on Jovie
none on it no that's not that way okay
it's good she knows okey boy boy Oh Gina
look ooh
what the [ __ ] um no no my hair Nagato
shove it to Dussel hmm mmm Dalton me you
knew exactly what you were doing
Colonel Joe Chiodo police channels ago
Mazda seen genomite Donna so lucky
huh yeah Kido Sycamore hold it oh hey
Keaney thumbnail Melissa Nia sweetie pie
Jesus
Japanese people seems to have a lot of
like empathy oh [ __ ] we walk right into
that [ __ ] oh no oh no it's that the boy
no what if we go back in [ __ ] that [ __ ]
you Utica oh there we go
all right Malloy touchy but I thought
blue spirits were okay oh god he's
coming isn't he mother of [ __ ] what am I
supposed to do what my mane oh thank god
oh god oh god I'm going I'm going [ __ ]
you bows closed both whatever the you
are oh [ __ ] oh god okay okay Kay Kay Kay
oh candle yes candle [ __ ] yeah yeah all
right let's keep going
I like this music more let's go back and
check in the hole because maybe teachers
back we don't know that she's not back
but we know that they don't know that so
I figured that it would be the thing to
do maybe they will I saw it with some
sort of dialogue
something I would never have happened
untouched looks like she hasn't come
back yet you Molly we need the door is
nailed shut all that kind of name you
just use a hammer to do that yeah of
course
[ __ ] yet my god I'm dumb I don't even
know although successfully is losing
every nail under the word the rusted old
nail puller broke apart in their process
well that's is still a win I'd say
there's a pie fiber there's a piece of
scrap paper pinned onto the wall you
know this dark spots done in the page I
realize her tear stains those who choose
to ignore the darkness that dwells in
the hearts of men may be stuck forever
in a loop for in this world there are
some truth that simply must be known no
matter how disturbing but curiosity can
be deadly
you know the truths our best left untold
we were the messages of the dead for
they for there be curses among them
curses at kidney can crush even the
strongest wheels demolishing all
semblance of reason if you wish to
protect your sanity take heed do not let
your curiosity get the better of you do
not read victims member are too
they're a conclusion we're back here now
whatever it is space thing a control
mechanism for some sort of elaborate
pulley system or a space thing I think
that's better explanation ripped off
with a network of find virtually
transferred threads there's a lever
jutting out from one side I don't see
what else we would do probably should
have safe oh it's like one of those so
that one's starting what how did we know
that it we'd like a little bit or just
we know that that is making sense hey
cherry alright the boys still here which
is bad news for us Oh boys
yeah I'm looking at you bit okay okay
okay
I guess we have to lure him down here
that's pretty good Oh God
oh [ __ ] come on that's how we do it ten
a-m you [ __ ] he's stuck there forever
okay we need to go up here I think I do
quite frankly hi skellies how you doing
good snips are growing as a matter of as
we speak I think I don't [ __ ] I don't
remember what it was was it in here the
word classroom is it here it's loading
yes
yes it is here okay let's just hope he
doesn't attack us from behind it's never
good to be attacked from behind it
appears to be a control mechanism from
sell-side elaborate because we knew this
yes yes and that opens what exactly a
bridge by the shoes a shoe branch
yes let's go oh [ __ ] I've got [ __ ] me
a second what do you do when this
[ __ ] music no no no oh [ __ ] what
what's happening
how the [ __ ] are we gonna do this oh god
oh god aah oh and what you gonna do
about that what you gonna do about that
huh what you gonna do about don't follow
me please don't you [ __ ] follow me
cuz I'm lost [ __ ] [ __ ] that's what i'd
not wanted him to do shut I sigh oh God
alright the Shoebridge the Shoebridge
where is it Dargis found it alright the
curse writings left behind by those who
lost all reason misread properly order
if you insist in reading such anyway to
have pretty strong but starting [ __ ]
thank you alright that oh okay okay KKK
we have a brush another branch thank you
thank you very much
seems like you can fail a lot more in
this one oh [ __ ]
don't be scared no Zach oh no shows you
your Moyer yes what are you me that's
really lose anything
hey you do what you want damn candle Oh
fantastic a lot of [ __ ] happened since
last time I don't know why we're going
into fir Murray that never ends well
last time last time last time shouldn't
the floor be broken after oh yeah it's
different universes so now we're
technically we're oh oh I know where we
are
Oh
I totally forgot where we're going now
this is not fair juggling by the size
ryu ahsoka katayama that sounds hot yeah
yeah well cooing ah cuticle take it
guess you're in a haunted mansion so
standard oh oh so he still feels the
pain even though he's a scary ghost okey
Tsubaki don't I tell you can take acid
and they feel it forever wonderful
absolutely wonderful
umm let's check our inventory do I have
anything no this game has very few items
save and quit no no okay
let's focus here oh yes now remember all
right oh god oh god oh god this is gonna
be bad
Nando Korea no no CBO what are they
talking about total kodachi Nemo
oh I see it Nauticus ended corner school
don't tell me what's going on oh oh I
got so many goose nips boy oh nice way
to ruin a moment with a [ __ ] bad shot
Jesus
oh she finds out about Seca
oh [ __ ] over here
no not die help sobbing this game is
[ __ ] weird mixing like porn and weird
horror and I don't know
that was weird seriously you could see
dye job girl
she's okay oh oh oh not this again it's
so creepy
that sound it's terrifying
what does it guy is no tameni not a
mistake little what I don't like when
your belly is another stir
oh oh she's - oh no gun yuck tonight
what does that mean so you gotta hinder
discussion - aye yo I like the voice
acting it's cool money
really don't act so innocent I don't
know
oh [ __ ] she's doing it again someone is
taking over her like oh [ __ ] what hell
no Mondial I need to go I got they are
Japanese angry
nananana Japanese life what is he doing
[ __ ] that
oh god no no no no no what happens if I
go near her she's just gonna be [ __ ]
up
Ayumi staring at us if transfix with an
unnaturally wide smile straight across
her face oh god alright that's AG that's
a good day I mean Tom I gotta go to this
evil fighting spirit that poor girl she
lost her mind and she'll never get it
back
the session is a frightful thing to have
your thoughts push deep down into the
pit of your soul and someone else take
their place really
[ __ ] it must be some way to save her
what do we do here
there has to be a better solution to
this what if we check the toilet nan de
Kooning oh we're so look at him ma-kun
you what I did it that's it as a dark
sinister shaving with a huge arena
that's it
what am I supposed to do then what's
going on oh gosh gallery' soda non dico
acutally what's gonna happen in uh a
back sorry nice yo crap nan da cunha
kimura takuya been Jawara mothers didn't
OVA Watteau O'Donnell here nice
background Sunni mogoon register aku be
dr. dena Garko expulsion famous
bondage Oh Massa non daigaku near no ah
ah car amo condo sorry t-bo thai
Tomodachi mo inai juno model yeah what
the hell is he do then sooner on I got a
toga kunio totally sorry Tomoko marooned
on ah ha no snow in the raw nan de
America amino agura
so Nakata conquer they were singing
about the college or you know in the
room there so ha ma eno-kun [ __ ] tank or
a Sudanese on shaman Denis record as an
AE Oman token o Goryeo samoto katana
he's such an [ __ ]
ha ha mucho add a kia rio orinoco
chapter Gaara yeah so resonator oh boy a
toast no G cocoon Atari or enema scotoma
light rod Satanism Nagato's jnana mata
go to na nina ricci retina Yoshino Jana
eat Giovanni codominant God's kuru Gaara
popping out babies of yo no naka
yoshinogari ngahiraka under na Na's
Chicana tuscany marina cocoa nieces
Gator Indian icon are coachable not a
yummy tiara no Micah beat the crap outta
jr. oh da ghetto stereo we added a
moment in the roll
oh no tengo ha ha ha ha no no no Mira
Oh coalition eat air does not decimated
on ah ha ha ego really do not the sensei
Oh
huh Oh angel none des jeux d'eau say say
no you'll be this signal secretion you
click recite ya sughar wallet ah hmm
she knows Aggie Oh Mon Ami honor it
smoke it to state a DD Cena sensei oh my
new eunuch what I skied ah ha ha ha hyah
me Arturo
Nando Masuda new GUI who the [ __ ] laughs
after a sentence like that why is there
no background psych Denis is it that's
funny
I'm not dumb aside there ha ha ha ha you
know did da so to stay to the show how
the hell did she now does he not I mean
I see no coochie goundamani nose here
are it a tiger Kooning up there son like
it's a lotta class canine whoa he did a
Momo aku Nina Rana Unni good girl cause
it it's either him or he thought they
are you Oh
since I didn't cry well nany night or
not so he's the bad boy and she's the
good girl knock on door take any another
two Amina Kaname didn't did she do that
often
you wanna chena murki ducky know what
that sound camino see no lucky at all
this about took their come in there oh
oh yeah oh oh y'all really not suck it
all killed over yonder top of course of
course
oh I don't like this
is she gonna kill me again she knows a
key see some mean ah model pic degree
she's okay oh yeah slow yachts or Amit's
get a dame de coco they're in the raw oh
my got some Angela Amin and I are come
on she nozaki are you me whatever Oh huh
she liked it
she knew muku Oh does it house you Oh
what what she was looking in the way ha
ha hey oh my god
this is being a pair right Callahan I'll
say he's explaining
so what you're saying such goddamn uni
student what shiranai stupid stuff look
it
kiyotsugu done lots of mommy tonight
singing orbiter
what's with the stain now eat it
she's personally georgian look to you
how do they root Olea
well we know it's not so salt not it
okay
yeah kiriona asked ck must it look good
you gotta tell us it's gone up dad
why will they not good well he did yell
out she knows okay screw so much on to
Easter
ah ha
Yuri sensei Volpone 9r she's [ __ ]
dead that's what [ __ ] old old mu book
all right let's go back to girl sodoes
the swedish nah
poor teacher though feel bad for the
teacher she got murdered so easily like
a little dignity dong so where what's
the classroom exactly I feel like it's
pretty far away maybe I missed something
oh [ __ ]
who was that should we follow to giddy
conversation of laughter can be heard
rafting out from the infirmary
what the [ __ ] girls giggling that's
creepy don't like what what is she
playing with that [ __ ] laugh kill it
kill now
hi this is a mother hugger
no she's [ __ ] bad no one laughs like
that if you look talk wait
guess your stash at all is that a
mushroom next time come on we found you
know we're gonna read it
heavenly pose four children abducted
follow every boy a brutal shocking
deaths on the reason kidnapped
grade schoolers have now been traced
back to the hands of the instructor
found in the room with them the scissors
he held are confirmed to have been used
to cut off the victims tongues
ultimately leading to death through
excessive bleeding or checked one of the
victims even had the majority of her
head slowly and methodically remove
there's our that's what I thought it was
a mushroom his cranial mass was found on
the floor next to her body
nice the heavenly host elementary
students pictured here are the four were
found in the patient room he's chillin
one was XXI resident winding that's
gonna ride at the scene of the crime
she was a little odd little the
newspaper is torn at this point the
bottom half of the article is mashing
she means she much go home as you sold
off why she doesn't have a face I don't
we got the picture yeah she sacrificed
no chassis no but uh Oh bill good night
Oh super cute Tommy Cooper building nah
they don't seem bad come on okay they're
bad they're bad really
the panties of her did we need to see
that tiny little detail was that really
necessary
oh wait I can pause now to make a five
six [ __ ] seven what the hell is wrong
man you all not enough
Japanese man there's such fun I got it
oh honey Sega top ow
I want to be on the safe side you never
know so what do we do leave her
I'm just gonna go and wash my hands and
just damn oh god that's nasty
what about you come and play
oh she sure does never talk how I guess
forget best thing is the lair so I
record my baby ninja sheep buddy does
good all day then what do we do then get
a room
of course my what DOMA house oh geez
well it's kind of it
Oh God living dial what Susan yeah
exactly
uh oh uh uh what death Ted based economy
tada bad fish
Coco Neto Zico Megara topic oregano
descender Sudha guru on tomcod Mita go
to myself Corrado atashi wa da cunha
koko de xin gameís my dad was a Hasini
cuckoo he musta well who was it I was
Costa hi
we know her name just cause he knows you
sino kena Xhosa oh she's like her Jonah
and Monica's Autotech tell every day
that our sources cannot really she's
famous Jehovah pigeon or superhuman hola
papa their homepage informal nice she's
a mouse not the time to fangirl hüseyin
Anka Chema's and querido
Shyama genesis Kusano Martina Nautica
goosing automata Takara Simpers date on
this kid oh so that's why she found it
out
Oh God go Tony no teton ante no suto
sake stone saga Sina Coco X Tati Donna
hi demon garage toga Latika kuduro hung
on oka corny sorry wha gomen nasai wine
i what the fire
sorry OD o Tomodachi gotta hinako Tanya
how does she know Dostana Anoka a rope a
rope I say Cuates eva koko de cinéma a
petro coke or anita Canoga cohesin ec
ravine hasta - Erica no a coca
10g sugar cookies a stair novo
wah Castellanos Decorah Sanjana Monaco
tajiki judo you me pens ok ok Saturday
Jake and a dance at Sarita Kodomo tachi
not a sake no Sima Ang's initial CNC
denote the de unico pseudonym but da sua
/ - it's got skated Canaima Sanders toga
enokitake no nail so you can't escape
are you uh oh do it again I cook on the
hawk I see my past agenda Muyo an adduct
I'm William ethic I host a career look
um so oh ma notice well I don't know if
I believe it oh so Connie tomorrow Tata
toaster in da caucus anonymity row SATs
a guy Hanley not Sangha - Anya
satsu go home ahsoka will kill them man
cause oniy ah tastes so good so let's I
did it
what did I need nanny got a king they
are what don't cry now
oh [ __ ] it's her okay no stereo Nantou
casinos
Oh - morichika
curry musta Donny Luca photo sagasta
Mimas wow she went our fast what my saga
Carino's cashier Allegro Shinji D'Amelio
yo ah nom de Mario die that's it awkward
so we're just gonna go and find a guy
that we didn't know existed and kill him
Oh guys it's gonna be bad oh god no oh
what does your cop
no I don't like this okay yeah what does
definitely you this hey can you feel
what they're get all through this shot
him boo boo Rosana Carla she knows okay
come on you that easy a little quit we
are vital Noguchi do you chew a little
girl Millie that's what you're wondering
right now really
okay let's find this man and destroy him
is that oh no it's that [ __ ] oh god I
hate him
why did I go here Oh
how does that even mean
was that lit up the front entranceway
might as well be painted out yeah but
it's wise and shirt yeah buddy yeah can
i car number gammon they are guess he's
a [ __ ] got dishes don't open okay
why are you me no good night
oh she wants me I mean no I didn't get
all she's brave
hon do you lose your nail
well you're blonde oh yeah oh my god who
does here no no don't sway too late like
they saw what stuck on that that I you
got Donny ouch
keep it in man keep it in clench your
buttcheeks alright
I see let's try not run into this guy
[ __ ] you don't like him at all
he's such an a-hole
we're heading back to the classroom
right isn't that it what is this
nice pickup Oh thoughts begin to echo
near mine
seemingly from the doll somehow or
another it's fun a way to communicate
its sole desire no doc
that's a cute little doll return my body
nice um could it possibly be - that girl
without a body you know what I don't
have any other leads so let's just go
with it I'm blond
okay we can we don't know what we do win
I appreciate it Imbert don't you want to
sound like a seal
really okay Shh he's stuck on the note
[ __ ] oh oh that was in the last
second later than Brea's oh god please
work oh no oh god I'm so effed in the
butthole
oh god oh oh is that that all there's an
old-fashioned festival darling I'm on
the ground there it seems amazing his
head pick it up yes thank you very much
thoughts begin to echo in your mind
seemingly from the doll somehow or
another it's find a way to communicate a
soul desire what that no no bare bare
ice crushed Mayo Kangas acquired and
cheek doll body to be specific as a head
and body of the antique boy all are
joined at begin speaking ba clearly and
directly
high-pitched voice like that of a child
it slowly repeats several phrases in the
cold methodical and almost robotic
monotone that's my jam
sure Jehan what's work
gotta love it all
nos where what do you know dummy
I don't know so we just grab it like
that
a penitent spirit yeah what the [ __ ]
it's not like you accidently cut off
someone's tongue in him well that's not
very nice
[ __ ] him [ __ ] you yes hmm
I don't like him at all why did he keep
following us don't he know who I am
oh he must be a fangirl huh
Shh man why don't you eat with our big
enough no that's about oil die get a ha
ha
now can a pathetically come on little
municipal day yes oh [ __ ]
how's that gonna work
my motto a Sarah konista
curse my luck demoiii no yo.hannes a day
keepo to vomit aha
hi Skinner poor girls dice can I go to
attend no Montoya happy touch nothing I
still don't trust this it's too easy
hey Kodaka I don't trust it see the
mother saw a nice jacket
I think since multiples live though oh
god what's happening
Oh God I don't know what's gonna happen
oh oh oh that did nuts
did we really [ __ ] up
no no nothing a little girl where are
they what happened guys there's yes oh
god no
Oh
uh-oh
Sookie no you google haha oh my god no
God
positi awesome not Esau I would too Oh
oh it's the killer no no [ __ ] don't you
dang don't you day I thought it would be
okay
oh she's she's ish what's gonna happen
here da no go cuckoo not Jesus
she soul I sense a honky receipt oh no
koto simple Stern okay yes doc I got an
e note Yoshida oh yeah demon Ike's innie
yes Oh yummy dynamo not yo huh Narasimha
diga que no hoko no se Sega Tomo Mina no
choreo cinema machina cry oh no katachi
ash Dilma Jesus Joshua God is she like
freakin superhero some tea
you gonna cry sorry Nemo Kodaka
additional testing uh okay Nemo Oh
Bernice redecorate a Genoa in Tanana yes
say General Thomas tornado sticker
sensing chipping in Craig that's all of
us
[ __ ]
too long
yeah
we know this yes
I need senator katakana oh my god ah
good stick continued in [ __ ] today yeah
it's so awesome I love every chapter so
far I understand already why people love
this game so much it's so cool how many
chapters are there again only five hmm I
thought this game was long anyway thank
you both so much for watching go ahead
and leave a like if you enjoyed this
chapter with me and excited for chapter
let me know in the comments and tell me
all about it
that being said I see bros with new
episode as soon as possible stay awesome
of your birth